bom dia a todos
em um cenário seria melhor que um
professor de matemática que estar diante
do xv dantesco completou 38 anos na
semana passada e à medida que vão
chegando mais perto dos 40 eu vou lhe
dando conta de que eu já sou um sujeito
nostálgico e eu sinto uma nostalgia toda
especial em relação a certos objetos de
que eu jamais imaginei que eu fosse
sentir falta até porque eles têm
substituto aprimorado tecnológicamente
hoje em dia por exemplo telefone de
descarga
eu jamais imaginei que eu fosse sentir
saudade não só do design que eu acho
mais bonito mais charmoso do que os
telefones de hoje em dia mas também de
uma expectativa que a gente criava toda
vez que a gente estava prestes a notar
um telefone novo e quem é meu
contemporâneo aqui certamente vai
entender a gente comemorava quando o
número de telefone exibir várias vezes
os dígitos 12 e 13
esses eram os bons a gente estava rápido
né
agora quando era 4567 a gente vai ficar
um pouco mais neutro e era uma desgraça
quando o número era composto pelos
dígitos 890 que a gente conseguia
acelerar a ida do disco mas a volta
tinha resistência
a gente não conseguia fazer com que o
vasco voltasse tão rápido quanto ele
nós sempre fomos pessoas ansiosas sempre
desde que a gente diz cava números no
famoso telefone de descarga
vou dar mais um exemplo e 1982 quando a
gente telefonava para alguém e esse
alguém não atendia
só havia telefone fixo não havia
identificador de chamada
a nossa opção era ligar de novo esperar
ligar mais tarde
de lá pra cá muita coisa mudou a começar
pela proliferação dominação mundial de
telefones celulares
alguns de vocês devem ter tido um desses
né tempo e mais tarde os sistemas de
mensagens instantâneas
começando pelo que mais tarde foi
substituído pelo msn e que mais
recentemente foi engolido pelo bate-papo
fez
buck nós continuamos telefonando uns dos
outros em 2012
a diferença é como a gente reage quando
esse alguém não nos atende o nosso
primeiro impulso é ligar de novo para
dar mais uma chance para aquela pessoa
ter a oportunidade eo privilégio
imediato de nos atender quando a pessoa
não nos atende novamente não passa pela
nossa cabeça que ela possa estar
impossibilitado de atender a gente manda
uma mensagem dizendo que liguei
como se não fosse suficiente dois
registros de chamadas do teu número com
nome telefone mandar mensagem dizendo
que ninguém quer falar contigo
em 1977 um sujeito chamado meus realizou
um estudo muito bacana estabelecendo um
vínculo entre o tempo de duração de uma
sala de aula de uma de uma aula melhor
dizendo que o percentual de alunos que
estão prestando atenção nela
vocês vão se chocar ao longo dos
primeiros cinco minutos
as pessoas estão agregando a sua atenção
ainda tem uma conversinha lateral ainda
tem uma notação que a gente está
terminando e tudo mais
a fusão pensar bom esse nível de atenção
se mantém pelo contrário é dramático é
assustador metade da aula transcorrido
apenas um em cada quatro alunos está
prestando atenção
até que chega aquele momento mágico em
que o professor diz finalmente e nesse
momento ele consegue resgatar algumas
das ovelhas desgarradas por dois motivos
primeiro porque as pessoas sabem que
normalmente normalmente professor deixa
o melhor final em segundo lugar se esse
professor não tiver deixado o melhor
final pelo menos ao final já é bom
quando as pessoas assistem a vídeos na
internet hoje em dia é curioso
transcorridos 10 segundos de qualquer
vídeo 89% das pessoas que começaram a
assistir a esse vídeo ainda estão
assistindo 11% já foi embora em 10
segundos
transcorridos 30 segundos do vídeo 30
dois terços das pessoas ainda estão
assistindo um terço já foi embora já
abandonou
se a gente chegar a um minuto de
reprodução de qualquer vídeo nota bem
independente da exibição independente da
duração e dão mais da metade
as pessoas já terão abandonado e se um
professor se presta a preparar um vídeo
de cinco minutos ou mais com todo o amor
com todo carinho todo cuidado de
produção
é bom que ele saiba que apenas 9% das
pessoas vão assistir até o quinto minuto
nove entre dez terão abandonado esse
vídeo
toda vez que eu entro em sala de aula
uma turma nova
eu me pergunto quanto tempo eu vou ter
para encantar seus alunos quanto tempo
eu voltei pra entusiasma eles para fazer
com que eles acreditem que aquilo que eu
tenho a dizer pode vir a ser
interessante matemática a gente estuda
com muita freqüência o conceito do zero
em oposição ao conceito do infinito ea
maioria das pessoas acha que 10 infinito
por representarem quantidades tão
diferentes nada e tudo por assim dizer
eles são conceitos antagônicos mas não é
curioso normalmente quando agentes barra
10 se a gente investigar a gente vai ver
que o infinito está bem próximo
um exemplo clássico da física na
velocidade por exemplo a gente aumenta a
velocidade do nosso automóvel porque a
gente quer reduzir o tempo para chegar
ao destino
a gente pode imaginar em matemática a
gente imprime uma velocidade de
atualmente infinita o tempo a chegar no
destino vai se aproximar cada vez mais
de 10 e consequentemente duas faces da
mesma moeda ficam assim revelat na idade
média
na baixa idade média ao século 12 13
surgiram as chamadas corporações de
ofício eram corporações em que mestres
ensinavam as aprendizes ofícios como
carpintaria marcenaria e por aí vai
nessas corporações havia obrigações
recíprocas o mestre tinha obrigação de
ensinar o aprendiz o ofício e de
proteger e amparar o aprendido o
aprendiz por sua vez devia obediência e
disciplina dedicação ao seu mestre
durante muitos anos séculos os ofícios
foram transmitidos assim de mestre para
aprendiz não havia escolas nas
bibliotecas eram restritas aos
monastérios né não havia gráfico tem
beijo não tinha nascido ainda alguém que
já passou por essa situação
o jovem tem três trabalhos para entregar
amanhã o primeiro trabalho sobre
trigonometria ele consulta trigonometria
e encontra 2.750.000 resultado
segundo o trabalho que ele tem para
fazer é claro ele vai imediatamente o
segundo trabalha sob citologia melhorou
menos de 2 milhões
o terceiro trabalho que ele tem para
fazer é sobre cinemática melhorou
bastante 1.630.000 resultados
todo mundo aqui já passou por isso nesse
momento a gente desiste
a gente tem coisa melhor para fazer
porque a gente se dá conta de um lance
muito importante a informação infinita
que é nos oferecida hoje pelos
mecanismos de busca ela se traduz na
prática o conhecimento zero
se não houver uma seleção de informação
relevante e o estabelecimento de
vínculos entre as informações relevantes
à informação infinita entende a 0 na
leitura do conhecimento e é nesse
momento que normalmente as pessoas
pensam seria ótimo se eu tivesse um
mestre
eu quero aprender o ofício da
trigonometria quero aprender o ofício da
citologia da cinemática eu devia ter um
mestre para me ajudar a me dizer o que é
relevante o que não é e para mais tarde
eventualmente dizer também o que é
importante em termos de como as peças
relevantes de informação se relaciona
eu nunca pensei seriamente em ser
professor é enquanto eu estudava para o
vestibular eu queria ser cientista da
computação
eu fui bem nos vestibulares barreiro uma
oportunidade começar a aula quando eu
tinha virtualmente a mesma idade dos
meus alunos até um pouco menos
também nessa época que eu transformei a
dependência de empregada da casa dos
meus pais em uma sala de aula e comecei
a reunir os meus aprendiz tentando
sempre mostrar pra eles que matemática
com esforço com dedicação pode ser uma
barbada a gente querer mesmo assim eu
continuei estudando me formei em
computação e concluir que havia chegado
a hora de descobrir o que era se era um
professor ou não sentido
foi aí que eu mandei
os estados unidos numa época em que a
minha vida cabe em duas malas e quatro
caixas de papelão
se eu pudesse resumir em uma única
imagem a minha temporada americana de
cinco anos eu vou escolher um dia de sol
em são francisco
foi lindo fazia três anos que estava lá
quando os meus colegas de trabalho
resolveram me premiar sinto muito
orgulho desse prêmio até hoje me
escolheram como analista do ano 99 isso
trabalho em equipe
mal sabiam eles que estavam nesse dia me
ajudando a decidir porque eles incluíram
textualmente no prêmio
eu estava sempre disponível para os
colegas como o professor fazia três anos
que trabalhava no mercado corporativo
americano
nesse dia descobrir eu jamais
conseguiria deixar de ser um professor
foi aí que resolvi voltar e aconteceu
isso aí as pessoas ficaram chocadas
perplexos a primeira coisa que as
pessoas disseram foi que estava
acontecendo
gustavo vai trocar o sonho americano
eu trabalho com adolescentes internos
irreverentes desinteressados às vezes às
vezes é indiferente o que é pior do que
se diz interessado optou por uma
profissão desprestigiada passa por uma
crise de identidade terrível uma crise
de autoridade pior ainda para completar
com aquele salário
a gente sabe segundo a educação precisa
de respostas essa campanha fantástica
revés da fazenda 2 por cento dos
estudantes do ensino médio e querem
seguir a carreira de professor eu acho
um exagero acho que é muito menos do que
isso
noventa por cento dos estudantes
completo ensino médio sem saber
matemática estava enlouquecendo ele quer
ser professor de matemática
ele podia ser o executivo podia ser um
médico ela só estudar fazer vestibular
de novo
podia custar direito se transformar num
jurista no magistrado respeitar mas ele
resolveu ser professor em cima disso
começaram as especulações
tem algo estranho aí o fracasso não sabe
se realmente foi demitido está voltando
a mão na frente e outra atrás
gustavo foi deportado
fantástico
no brasil a gente tem que ser
socialmente resistentes a gente quer ser
professor
a gente é alvo de piada toda hora mas
quando a gente decide uma coisa a gente
quer mostrar às pessoas que a gente
tomou a decisão certa
foi isso que eu tentei fazer a compra à
classe as cadeiras quadros e disse vou
montar meu cursinho e resolvi começar a
trabalhar e tem muita aula sábado
domingo feriado do dia manhã tarde noite
da aula criança viu da aula cansa
bastante
as pessoas acham que nem trabalho é foi
aí que a gente percebeu e tinha criado
um lugar em que as pessoas se sentiam
bem e eu tinha o resultado foi que eu
chamei o marceneiro e disse vamos então
na madeira e de verde jogar uma luz em
cima dela
vou comprar um quadrinho em dourado lado
dessa maneira vou começar a jogar às
aulas na internet só pra ver no que dá
e assim foi de lá pra cá a gente tem se
focado em aulas ao vivo via internet por
exemplo nem 2012 nós reunimos mais de
cinco mil alunos de 25 estados mais o
distrito federal só faltou o acre mas
dizem que o pac não existe
me pediram para vir aqui falar sobre
inovação na educação
eu fiquei pensando o que é inovação na
educação da maioria das pessoas
cheguei à conclusão de que inovar na
educação é simplesmente ensinar alguma
coisa para alguém
muita gente jamais teve a experiência de
ensinar algo para alguém que critica
quem decide ser professora sem jamais
ter passado pela experiência de ensinar
alguém a fazer qualquer coisa
quando vocês que nunca experimentaram
ensinar alguém a experimentar e vocês
vão se dar conta de que a gente não tem
como ser um bom professor sem ser
completamente generoso sem oferecer
melhor que a gente tem sem sonegar há
absolutamente nenhuma informação e essa
generosidade nos alimenta e não só isso
no momento que a gente é generoso a
gente oferece às pessoas a oportunidade
de manifestarem a sua gratidão
isso é absolutamente fantástico porque a
gratidão ea generosidade elas criam um
núcleo mágico em que uma alimenta a
outra a gente se torna mais generoso à
medida em que as pessoas expressam a sua
gratidão e vice versa as pessoas são
ingratas quanto mais generoso a gente é
como se não bastasse as pessoas
testemunham isso acontecendo e resolvem
se inspirar e serem também generosa e na
medida em que surgem mais pessoa
generosa surgem mais pessoas graças mais
pessoas se inspiram e tudo melhor inovar
na educação não é tão difícil assim
renovar a educação é um somatório é o
somatório da generosidade na gratidão e
da inspiração experimento vocês que
nunca deram ao experimento ensinar
alguma coisa pra mim
muita gente me pergunta a gustavo não se
arrepende de ter voltado
já ouvi isso um milhão de vezes e agora
talvez seja porque eu tô chegando perto
dos 40 mas cada dia que passa eu me
convenço mais de que o arrependimento é
o inverso da convicção
e à medida em que eu vou dando aula eu
vou ajudando mais pessoas essas pessoas
se tornam gratos e se inspiram
eu percebo que a minha convicção vai
aumentando ea impressão que eu tenho é
de que quando chegar no final da minha
carreira na minha convicção ter atendido
ao infinito
e aí você já sabe nem quanto à convicção
tem definido seu arrependimento muito
provavelmente vai atender 00 infinitos
são na verdade as duas faces da mesma
moeda
obrigado
[Aplausos]